our great ally Egypt I'm very conflicted
about Egypt I think they're kind of
trying to do some good stuff they've had
you know between the coos that maybe did
happen or didn't happen and uh you know
what's going on with the new president
they're they're they're sort of trying
to be a good country and then they kind
of go backwards a little bit they just
arrested seven people after their first
gay wedding with Stiglitz video
I mean that's the sound of joy people is
that the sound of joy created it's a lot
of tongue that would be a good list
that's a great lesbian that's like the
call of the lesbians that I couldn't
work out perfect you do that I don't
make that sound like a Mexican it's
about yeah uh well let's just assume
that was a good sound I think it was a
good sound there we don't we never get
those images out of the Arab world
something progressive happening and joy
and gay rights there's a lot of good
there but of course then the seven
people get arrested uh the public
prosecutor's office released a statement
saying that the act was humiliating
regrettable and would anger God Jaclyn I
know you know field day with this God
fella uh they remain in custody for up
to four days and it's a little bit
unclear what's gonna happen to them now
by the way Egypt and they're not the
only country in the Arab world that has
this and they have medical tests medical
tests uh for gay people where they try
to figure out if you're gay and I don't
even want to get into how they do that
but we've talked about it before um to
me this is the type of story that
everybody in our media should be talking
about all the time because you know when
when Russia had the thing in the Sochi
Olympics uh everyone was going crazy and
yet for some reason when something good
starts happening in the Middle East we
don't talk about it and we should be
talking about this shouldn't we and and
bringing to light what they're doing but
also showing that there are little rays
of light coming out of that place yeah I
mean he saw the video they seemed so
happy there was nothing wrong going on
in that video but they were still
charged with what publishing indecent
images really yeah and I'm pretty sure
it's not about the video that they put
up it's about the actual act that
there's right there do I mean well I
think it's also about the video because
they're representing them as a country
and their people and I think that that's
where you know those people can't
genuinely be tied to our nation and
whatnot I mean this is a blatant example
of human rights violation in so many
regards like I actually did look up them
what the medical testing
you know and it's like making these
people get on their hands and knees
pantsless and massaging stimulating
essentially and penetrating their anal
cavities and like that sounds like a
good Friday night that's a pretty good
that sounds really [ __ ] yay but like
I'm just saying like that it's literally
in so many aspects of things if that
were to happen anywhere else I feel like
we would be talking about I think it's
because it's the middle east area right
now I think there's other other
situations that are trumping and they
don't wanna I don't know so why would he
make it out how we pick and choose these
things so we're all outraged and
remember we were boycotting vodka even
though it turned out that Stoli vodka
was made in like Latvia or something but
we were boycotting the wrong vodka
company cuz we were so upset about what
they were doing the gays Egypt they're
doing this homosexuality is illegal in
every literally in every Arab country I
think there's ten that you can be put to
death in in Africa so why don't we get
upset about this I think people live in
a little bubble that we call America and
we don't really look at what's going on
in other places as much as we should
people just don't think it applies to me
I live here you know they're all there
so far for me it doesn't apply you know
for some reason people just care less
and that's sad but I think things like
this are great because we can get
discussions going and hopefully bring
more attention to it yeah why do you
think there's an obvious connection to
where they treat gay people well is
pretty much all the places that
civilized people would want to live
what's the connection between being okay
with gays and then pretty much
everything else being sort of okay there
seems to be a through line there I mean
I think it's a more just a more
libertarian mindset a more openness and
you know free speech free action it is
allowed and people enjoy freedom so you
know if if you can live your lives and
and and be free and be happy it's just
the place I would want to flock to that
area as opposed to flocking to you know
Egypt or the Middle East where I have to
wear like a full cover I don't know I
mean this isn't the first time this has
happened either where it's actually been
there's been a larger scale arrest in
2001 there was 52 arrested on a some
luxury boat of a gay
Club in Egypt as well and it's just like
the wrong foot to get gay people to
death last year I mean yes I mean this
the fact that this is still happening is
something that needs to be brought up as
a worldwide discussion like I think that
I think that those countries that do
have the liberties of being who you are
and being out in being gay and living
your life I think should this should be
an area that should be interjected on
yeah I mean that's my opinion maybe
that's because I'm part of this
community I feel so invested into it but
then again I feel the old opinion like
it is my student union it is but I feel
like if there were lesbians and they
were doing this it would there wouldn't
even be a video because they'd be like
women exist yeah what do you mean maybe
totally shot so we just did a segment on
immigration do you think we should treat
gay people in other countries and
countries where it is criminalized as
refugees if these people wanted to have
refugee status should we grant them that
I mean personally I would say yes just
because I'm worried about everybody I
feel like you know what I feel so bad
for what they have to go through and
it's not right and I would love to help
them but I find it hard to believe that
we would do that as a country when we
still haven't legalized gay marriage
everywhere here yeah I mean we're not
gonna dad but let me just give you in
society it would just be like a big
Priscilla Queen of the desert blood
coming through from all different
countries just full of like you know
worldwide Queens yeah sounds awesome
sounds like a documentary I want to make